little doggie sauces things ready to go  [Music]  burger show is back baby this is  straight-up porn to me get ready for  another season of classic burgers by  definition a burger has to be ground  beef cooked somehow served on bread and  that's it  all right I like that it's not just  three little stupid meatballs on a bad  brioche bun pasta Kelly fir to me are  like pretty simple with like one  defining feature that's the things I  used to say about boyfriends comedic  shenanigans that cheese is melting so  pretty I'm gonna shut that [ __ ]  burger and Linda just sued me tonight  legs alone happy a drive-through  American cheese I didn't have to say in  this raccoon fajita is his specialty I  heard Texas baby hurts very and hitting  the road with everyone's favorite burger  daddy the most man this burger is unlike  anything you'll ever see  whoa whoa well that's good that's like  some stoner burger right there not  [ __ ] good the Burger Chef Season five  all right let's do the roll